hi my name is Claire Danes and I am
decidedly giddy about being
Conan O'Brien's friend that's are you
sure the giddiness
is about me
or were you doing nitrous recently no I
I yeah no I am you are it's very nice to
see you again nice to see you again I'm
going to say something that uh I hope
this comes out right but this is how I
feel whenever I meet people as I met you
many many many many many years ago quite
a few moons when you came on the show
and probably for my so-called life or
something you know just like something
ancient something uh and
I have this feeling and I've said this
to uh Like Scarlett Johansson who was on
as a child actor she she was in a sketch
that we did oh really where she played a
uh
we we build her as a uh the spelling bee
Champion oh and then we brought her out
and we didn't tell the audience it was
all a hoax and she couldn't spell her
way out of a paper bag which was the
joke but I'll see you or her and I'll
think
um I'm like your uncle or something
because I you've all I mean like you've
done so well and then I have this weird
Pride which is misplaced because I've
had nothing to do with your life I've
done nothing other than
um have you on the show a couple of
times and so I've in no way contributed
to your success but I still have this
kind of weird quasi-paternal thing that
I don't quite understand that's very
sweet and I will take that Pride
um gladly and uh hungrily yeah no that's
Father's Day is coming up
yeah I have also have a very nice memory
of my wife and I this was a long time
ago in Seattle yes at the Museum of rock
and roll or something yeah it's like the
music experience experience Music Museum
and we're walking along and I'm my wife
and I our relationship is not that you
know it's like we've we've I think we're
newly married or recently married or
maybe even not married yet and you came
running up to me and were really nice to
me and my wife was like you know Claire
Danes and I was like yes yes I do I know
many people and that's my job that may
have sealed the deal for me that may
have like gotten me my wife okay of 21
years so good for you yeah I remember it
too it was quite exciting seeing you so
out of context yes yeah I remember uh
that very well there's just like these
little flash moments you have
um and we have so much to talk about
because
uh I saw this uh this show that you did
recently uh fleischmann's in trouble and
I was interested in it right away
because I adore you I adore Jesse
Eisenberg it's a good girl I love Lizzy
cat I mean it's just like this is as and
I had this thought of they're getting
some of my favorite people together to
do a project and watched it and and I
was floored by what you did in that uh
in that I don't know I want to call it a
movie because it's not a TV show it's
cereal you know what do we call them now
I think we call them limited series
which is like a schmancier version of
mini series which had a very different
connotation exactly so long ago yeah
it's uh there were so many things that
like after school special yes exactly no
it was it's not about you know vaginal
discharge or something
um I was disappointed because I tuned in
thinking that's what I was gonna see
um and uh we'll talk about it a little
more later because I don't want to give
anything away but
um that floored me and it shouldn't have
surprised me because uh you know the
work that you've done throughout your
career is so good oh thank you and um I
know you hear this a lot and it's it's
it's interesting to me because
knowing you just a little bit as
yourself
you are so good at playing these people
who are going through something
torturous and who are just being crushed
by like seismic plates of emotion you're
so able to do that and then when I see
you you're just the lightest most fun do
you know what I mean you're effervescent
and fun and and uh great laugher and I
think man she's a good actress yeah I
know it's funny I I I don't know it was
it's so exquisitely real well written
this show and
um and you know it's this great magic
trick that Taffy is able to uh uh create
both in her novel and in in the series
um I have to say I mean I felt so
supported by
the material and the people that I was
making the thing with and yeah it's you
know it's taxing and risky to venture
into those dark crevices
um of The Human Experience but I so
believed in the thing and was so excited
to have a chance to you know explore
these themes and and these experiences
that are so
under represented in pop culture
um that uh you know I I felt really
invested and
and
able to do it and there's even some kind
of joy in it I mean I I think
because I know it's in service
potentially of something worthwhile you
know like
I mean sometimes it's much harder to do
a kind of technically easy scene with
wonky writing than a really exacting
demanding scene with excellent writing
like it carries you there's Brian
Cranston said
um he said as an actor
I can get the material if the material
is like an a I might be able to get you
to an A plus yeah yeah but he said if
the material is a c
I can get you to a c plus yes if I'm
really like totally on game or maybe it
would be minus but he said the the you
know really has to be on the page
absolutely you know we are talking about
this during this writer strike and it's
appropriate to bring up like here here
that that is uh
I I know there's so many people that
think
um they'll watch a show
uh a drama and there are many people
that think the writers are just kind of
making it up as they go along almost
like you could watch Citizen Kane and
yeah Orson Welles got Joseph cotton a
couple of people and they just kind of
improved and then they came up with that
sled thing in the end isn't that crazy
totally and it's amazing yeah and having
spent so much of my time within
television I'm you know acutely aware of
how vital the writer is in the process
and the intimacy that you start to have
with your writing Partners on a series
is kind of uh unmatched I mean it's it's
it doesn't really exist to the same
extent in any other medium so I have
just like the deepest of of respect for
writers and and I'm you know really
aware of how much I owe to them